hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today serves up
Thrills chills and a free twist at no
extra charge are you a kid that sees
dead people perhaps an extraterrestrial
who hates hydration have you yet to find
what your max bench press is then you
might be a character in an M Night
Shyamalan joint regardless you're all
welcome here no matter if you're a 19th
century villager an odd duck grandparent
or a watery tart who loves a late night
swim I saw you
I saw you I'm your host Mark Allison on
this episode of versus you and all your
many personalities are encouraged to
enjoy a scintillating video essay that
will Proclaim one Shyamalan film the
greatest of them all for the time being
anyway a knock at the cabin is his new
flick and if you are in fact a movie
character that's bunking at a remote
Lodge deep in the woods you're praying
that anyone other than night is your
director
can you open the door please you see bad
things tend to happen in his flicks but
us audiences can't wait to see what new
surprises lurk around every Bend of the
latest Shyamalan experience and his
career in Hollywood thus far when you're
talking about twists and turns he was
knighted as the new master of suspense
after a stupendous array of critical and
box office successes during the turn of
the century then that heat cooled off to
the point of being frozen out of
Hollywood's in-demand director Rolodex
but then he self-financed the comeback
for the ages and is once again crafting
quality entertainment that titillates
the senses preys on our fears and keeps
us on the edge of our seat
please
in case some of you know him as the icy
dead people guy or the dude responsible
for bending air in some very
questionable directions here's a quick
recap of the movies that will be in
contention today Wide Awake The Sixth
Sense unbreakable signs the village Lady
in the Water The Last Airbender After
Earth the visit split glass and old plus
I'll toss in Devil a film that he
produced and created the story for ooh
can we sneak in Stuart Little too
no really raise your hand if you knew
that he wrote the screenplay for that
adorable little mouse flick it was
released a few months after the sixth
sense and it's safe to say that there's
less ghosts in Mr whittles film I think
I you never know between mouse traps and
hungry kitties the point is we can't
trust M night as far as where his movies
are going but we can usually rely on him
to give us a worthwhile movie watching
experience here's how we'll determine a
winner round one box office round two
Tomato Meter slash audience score round
three characters round four memorable
moments and then we'll do a Wild Card
round which we do on every episode of
versus it's our own little surprise
ending What's It Gonna involve maybe the
best minor league baseball player the
scariest villain the protagonist who
eats the most geez
cheese and crackers I'm telling you do
not count Stuart Little out in this
contest last certainly not least I do
want to hear from you let me know what
your favorite Shyamalan flick of all
time is comment or hit me up on the
social media if you're not on Twitter or
Instagram or Tick Tock or I don't know
LinkedIn then just send a villager
through the woods to deliver the message
to me in person ah the village times
were simpler back then in the 1800s okay
we're expecting a visitor at my cabin
any minute so it's time to swing away
and determine the goat of M night's
career let's get it on one two three
round one box office
way back in 1999 not many people had
heard of this young filmmaker named
minosh Night Shyamalan born in India
raised in Suburban PA and looking to
make his Mark in the entertainment
industry his first feature Wide Awake
had debuted the year before but the
limited theatrical release didn't make
much of a dent at the bank taking in
just three hundred thousand dollars then
1999 happens and all of us film goers
were sipping Mountain Dew with Darth
Maul on the cans stumbling around the
found footage Woods of burkettsville
Maryland and weighing our options about
which color pill to ingest that summer
like a pay-per-view wrestling match a
surprise Contender entered The Fray and
The Sixth Sense would go on to a mask
672 million dollars around the globe
a shocking twist that would become a
night Hallmark likely buoyed that
impressive amount of coin as no one
wanted to be spoiled on the ending
before getting to witness it themselves
sadly I did not make it in time and one
of my good friends squawked the surprise
we're still good pals I'm keeping him
around until I get to have a Revenge
with a movie that has an even bigger
climactic shock could it be a knock at
the cabin The Sixth Sense had a super
high bar for all Shyamalan projects to
follow his sophomore effort unbreakable
held strong in the year 2000 hauling in
248 million dollars then signs crop
circled over 400 million dollars in
2002. all right so we got three big time
releases under our belt and three home
runs including the Grand Slam knocked
out by The Sixth Sense the village
arrived in 2004 and kept plenty of coal
in the fire with a 257 million dollar
take it wasn't until 2006 that Knight
fell back down below that legendary
hundred million dollar line when the
Lady in the Water paddled up to 72
million dollars which still sounds
pretty good the happening rebounded with
162 million dollars one what no then The
Last Airbender conjured more than 300
million bucks in 2010 and that's all
we're gonna say about that outing for
now since after Earth split and glass
have all shattered the 200 million
dollar ceiling and the visit and old
each got within shouting distance of a
hundred million dollars old was released
in 2021 when audiences were still in the
midst of a global happening we all
remember it and the visit is memorable
just because it costs 5 million dollars
to make that five mil was directly out
of shamwan's own pocket by the way that
was an expensive trip to grandma's house
but we turned one hell of a profit so
what if she acts a little eccentric when
the Sun goes down I really like that
movie
now but this round ain't about liking
it's about big fat money and while a
handful have come close no Shyamalan
effort has matched the box office power
of the sixth set wait a minute good God
that's Stuart Little's music beloved by
generations of readers a major marketing
campaign fun for kids of all ages could
it Scurry past the dead people movie no
no it can't almost 300 million dollars
in cheddar goes a long way I'd let em
write another movie about a mouse
whenever he wants but the Sixth Sense is
the richest kid on the Block and it
earns the first point of the day by
winning round one it's Haley Joel Osment
one the rest of the field zip
we almost got you bro
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score and now we leap into the round
that is sure to reward Shyamalan in his
loyal stance it's here where we look at
the critics and audiences feelings about
the director's films after they saw them
it's gonna be a hoot because both sides
of the aisle bestowed tonight with
nothing but admiration for a while then
they didn't then they did again and now
well I hope that knock of the cabin is
more than just Publishers Clearinghouse
don't do this to me again dude got going
with a bang that's right Stuart Little
is fresh at 67 percent but I'm actually
referring to the Sixth Sense oh wait
time out his first actual feature 1998's
Wide Awake is rotten on the Tomato Meter
at 45 percent but fresh on the audience
score scale with a 66 percent so all
told it's actually looking better than
Mr Whittle who only hit 41 with
audiences who hated Stuart Little what
did you think you were getting it's a
talking Mouse Michael J fox you get what
you pay for is it just me or did he seem
a little disappointed unless of course
you pay to see the sixth sense in that
case you got a whole lot more than just
a thriller one of the radish turns in
film history helped woo critics and
audiences as night's breakout hit landed
at 86 percent on the Tomato Meter and 90
percent with the normies unbreakable
continued the trend of good with critics
better with the schmoes to the tune of
70 percent of the veggie patch and 77
percent with the audience signs would
pile on the freshness with a 75 Tomato
Meter but then the village began a slide
that threatened to sideline shyamalan's
career way too early the period piece
wink wink hitch is 43 percent then lady
in the water sunk to 25 percent it's
worth noting that audiences dug these
pieces a little more but still in rotten
territory The Happening hit an all-time
low in 2008 when it flooded with a 24
for the audience and an abysmal 17
percent on the Tomato Meter that's gonna
be a yikes but we weren't done doing the
limbo how well can you go hey why can't
anybody give me a damn second The Last
Airbender was about as Rocky a bottom as
it gets five percent on the Tomato Meter
it costs an estimated 150 million
dollars to accomplish that somehow did
rise up to 30 with the audience but by
this point the critical stench
associated with M was so potent that
when devil hit theaters a few months
later a film that he wrote the story for
and produced his name was barely visible
in the marketing materials it did okay
49 of the Tomato Meter but then 2013
brought us right back down to well after
Earth was 12 it's a bummer of a time for
Shyamalan fans like me you're rude for
the guy but I remember seeing his name
attached to movie trailers and audible
laughs happening in the theaters where
those previews were playing he'd become
a punchline in the industry a golden boy
who could never live up to his early
promise why are people gonna suddenly
take me seriously but like a hungry
boxer who had fallen on hard times he
went back to his roots self-financing
his next effort 2015's the visit and as
a result it was back in fresh territory
when the found footage Thriller notched
68 on the major day tomato but it wasn't
until 2016's split that both critics and
audiences agreed that night was truly
back your heart is pure
Rejoice 78 on the TM 79 with audiences
and I was in a month's early screening
of that flick when the twist happened at
the very end the crowd went Bonkers nuts
mines were lost strangers arms grabbed
it was like Yoda just lit up his
lightsaber again Mass hysteria in the
coolest safest sense of the word more
recently glass and old both missed out
with being fresh with critics though
glass cut into fresh fill with the
audience at 67 percent so where do we go
from here some say he's back others
contend he'll never reach the heights of
his first three releases sorry Stewart
his first four wide releases I think in
hope he has a long productive career
ahead of him as of today his best scores
on either metric are the sixth sense I
caught it again last night and not only
is it worthy of those gaudy digits but
it might be the last movie where Bruce
Willis has hair I think maybe we should
investigate that the Sixth Sense gets
the W in round two and we're just
looking for another movie to step up and
make this competitive and one of us has
made a gross error and wasted the other
person's valuable time
round three characters
oh we got a shot here and a round that
will be won by the individual film that
features the best characters individuals
ensembles I'm so bummed I haven't seen
knock at the cabin yet and without
kicking a movie while it's down if we
add in The Last Airbender Source
material stick of fork in round three
because that's winning why are you
acting this way but we can only go by
the movie and well you can bend all the
area one don't hold your breath here the
film that will likely emerge as the
winner in this round either needs to
feature a monster Cavalcade of memorable
roles and performances or Star big names
that shine in one of the best films of
their storied career or maybe we can aim
for both The Sixth Sense gave us Bruce
Willis near his Apex back in 99. we also
got Donnie Wahlberg Post New Kids on the
Block but pre-history days does he help
his brothers with a burger joint was it
Wahlburgers eight there one time solid
Burger really good Pale Ale sense
obviously that was a breakout role for
Haley Joel Osmond as well but what
really struck me upon re-watching it is
how amazing Tony Collette is throughout
the film Bruce is the star carries the
load but Colette went such an endearing
humanity and we feel such empathy thanks
to her emotional raw last straw sort of
presence it's great stuff but both The
Sixth Sense and unbreakable have limited
casts albeit ones that make the most of
their time on screen and reuniting die
hard and Pulp Fiction alums Bruce and
Samuel L Jackson was a stroke of Genius
by Shyamalan I think this is where we
shake hands then signs amped up the star
power even more featuring a pre-nut bar
Mel Gibson Joaquin Phoenix Kieran Culkin
and Abigail Breslin oh and there's ETS
in it did you all know that they're
there plus Cherry Jones comedy nerds
like myself will also note the
appearance of Michael Showalter who got
his first start on MTV with the state
I'm Doug man I'm out of here anybody
remember that all right moving on
okay the village now that's a real
Contender we've dealt with family units
thus far but now we got a whole little
Township trying to keep mysterious
Woodland creatures at Bay William Hurt
Sigourney Weaver Brendan Gleason and
Company play the town Elders the young
ends coming up include Judy Greer Bryce
Dallas Howard Joaquin Phoenix and Adrian
Brody plus a super precocious Jesse
Eisenberg I was so bummed watching that
movie in theaters I still maintained
that the trailers promised a very
different flick but upon revisiting it I
think it's one of Knight's best efforts
and certainly a shining example of what
a killer ensemble cast can do
but sometimes he can have killer and
Ensemble all within one human being
enter Kevin Wendell crumb perfectly
played by James McAvoy crumb has a whole
bunch of folks living inside his head no
less than 23 and by the end of the film
split a new scarier creature emerges
from the pack so all that film's setting
is relatively isolated like most of
nights work there's so many different
characters that the audience gets to
meet plus Anya Taylor joy and a very bad
uncle bad uncle I'm tempted to take
split here because it's a great film but
as far as cast goes the follow-up glass
tossed Sarah Paulson Samuel L Jackson
and Bruce Willis back starring this time
into the Vitamix glass may not be as
rotten in my household as was on the
Tomato Meter but there's no arguing that
the town assembled and their
performances therein are worthy of
winning the point in round three
knocking the cabin has an impressive
collection of people but for today glass
gets on the board and cuts the lead of
The Sixth Sense in half good for you
round four memorable moments but back to
the that breakout hit and Tony Collette
my goodness that woman is a revelation
in the sixth sense so yeah we love the
twists and turns and reveals but for me
it's the moment when she's at her Wit's
End trying to understand her son Cole
they're stuck in traffic it's some sort
of accident ahead and he's telling her
his secret finally her mom is involved
she did end up going to that dance
recital decades ago tears flow and Bam
that's how you close out a winning piece
and the lead up to that ain't bad either
the terrifying opening that veers from a
champagne celebration to a break-in to a
shooting it locks the audience in for a
creepy Thrill Ride I also love the
scares brought by the many ghosts that
Cole interacts with and then of course
we have the scene
the line delivery is perfect as is
Willis's reaction that goes from
psychiatrists to just middle-aged dude
peeing himself like the rest of us the
danu ma was a massive reveal and a
beautiful close to a relationship Gone
Too Soon it kind of reminded me of ghost
in a way speaking of who wins in a fight
in their Prime Bruce Willis or Patrick
Swayze he got Dalton from double deuce
or John McLean comment below I want you
to remember
that it's a job
it's nothing personal old was a really
sweet Treatise on Aging at the beach it
was basically like watching the State of
Florida in super fast forward mode but
it did come with some stupendous getting
old in a hurry Thrills meanwhile the
visit utilized found footage to conjure
jump scares at the grandparents house
both inside and underneath remember
seeing granny crawl around under the
first floor someone get that later
Wednesday pills and I can't even defend
The Last Airbender well maybe a little
for all the criticisms that you can
rightfully lob at this misfire the
special effects are cool and a lot of
the fight scenes Stand Out shout out to
Sean tube and Asif manvi for doing their
very best to inject some acting chops
and personality into this thing all
right can we talk about devil now bro
take it easy okay it's only 80 minutes
but you're on the edge of your seat the
whole show stranger stuck in an elevator
one of them may in fact be the dark lord
Satan and the lights flickering indicate
that a kill is just around the corner
very inventive simple yet scary and when
you see a face pop onto the security cam
feed it jolts you to the Core
but for me signs has pound for pound the
best moments of any Shyamalan project
yes including you Stuart you adorable
Mouse bastard crop circles I'm in it's
one of night's most straightforward
Tales but the ride is expertly paced and
fraught with jumps creeps and chills we
don't know what's causing those crop
thingies but tucking your daughter in at
night and glancing out the window
indicates that the perpetrators may not
be of this Earth then we get the
flashlight drop and seeing a green thing
in the corn fields that doesn't look
like a stock I personally enjoy the
creature in the pantry scene while we
cut back to the homestead and Joaquin
Phoenix is glued to the news where we
see one of the scariest moments I've
ever experienced in a movie theater the
birthday party oh that's one frightening
looking being and I don't think it comes
here in peace now some folks will argue
that the end of this film when we find
out these visitors are allergic to water
is the weak link why would they come to
a planet that 70 water if they were
allergic uh maybe because they were
really keen on harvesting the other 30
do you know how fast we've been be on
Neptune if there was oil discovered
there I don't care if it's 99 deadly if
there's black gold Texas Tea to be found
humans are going
then we get the harrowing backstory of
Mel losing his wife in an accident the
guy who accidentally hit her is the
director of the movie Tom I'll need a
ride home there's fantastic comedy in
the flick that doesn't detract from the
scariest signs is basically one long
iconic moment might be my favorite of
all the M Night shyamo on flicks and it
does enough here to earn the point and
get on the board signs wins round four
and now it's the Sixth Sense two glass
one and signs one
[Music]
I think someone did and now it's time
for the Wild Card round a toast to World
Peace well that certainly doesn't happen
in signs although I could argue that us
humans really came together to defeat
ETS using a primitive method and maybe
afterwards we all got along better of
course then you have the village which
is a population of what 50 people at the
most and even that tiny group can't see
eye to eye it is too painful I cannot
bear it so instead of figuring out which
movie got us the closest to World Peace
I'll instead borrow from Andy McDowell
in Groundhog Day she likes to toast
World Peace while sipping on a sweet
vermouth with a Twist
Bing come on do you think Uncle Mark
wasn't gonna highlight all the shocking
turns and revelatory twists that make
Knight's films purr in fact if this
round was about world peace the winner
might have been The Last Airbender think
about it the flick is about uniting the
four elements and its denizens in each
and it was pretty much universally
panned we all hated it so all earthlings
can agree on stuff but no I want to see
once and for all which one of the
Shyamalan flicks took us on the best
ride and gave us the twistiest you know
twist very funny the Sixth Sense is a
good place to start oh did I mention I'm
spoiling stuff here because I am here's
a warm-up one the mouse can talk and do
a Marty McFly impression thank you for
your time Stuart okay so Bruce Willis
was in fact a ghost as he was trying to
help a young boy who sees dead people
it's an Alzheimer and particularly well
played from a casting standpoint this is
a-lister Bruce Willis in 1999. the dude
never dies in anything hell he's the guy
from die hard he might have eaten it and
Death Becomes Her I can't remember but
in a thriller like this come on it's a
great surprise ending it's also fun to
go back and watch from Young Cole's
perspective did he know his shrink was
dead did he find out along the way did
you know it all along never realized it
the movie toys with all three
possibilities very very well unbreakable
also had a sizable pivot in that David
Dunn's superhero power was Unearthed not
by a train accident I mean yeah the
train crashed but it was on purpose in a
stunt device by Mr glass specifically to
see if there was an opposite
indestructible Force to his incredibly
frail body I know who I am
the visit had a fun one too so we're
going to see the grandparents or at
least we assume that these Elders are
related to us I mean they're old right
they got to be pop-up and Nana nope
they're just Escape mental patients on
the loose the upside is you might be
able to talk them into more free candy
okay so there's tons of goodies when it
comes to being shocked by an ending
courtesy of M Night Shyamalan for me
this comes down to a three-way brawl you
got your Sixth Sense the most famous
turn of all so it's in the Triangle then
we have split when it's learned that the
events we just witnessed take place in
the same universe as unbreakable did
this is so cool both of these turns
involve Bruce Willis The Sixth Sense
employed his Fame and penchant for not
dying which is easy to trick us split
had him working in the weeds like a lion
patiently waiting until just before the
credits rolled to pounce but my third
finalist might be the best and it
doesn't involve Bruno the one we talk
about not the one from Encanto The
Village I know it left you cold that we
didn't actually get to battle a bunch of
hungry monsters in the forest I was
bummed too but the twist is that we're
not actually in the 1800 it's modern day
and this community is comprised of folks
so bitter about tragic twists and turns
in their own existences that they band
together to form a society that hearkens
back to a simple time you know one
without medicine or dentist I think
that's my winner in this round it was a
complete shock and for a few moments the
film does play with a concept that maybe
there actually are wolf-like things
hiding just beyond the wooded barrier
you're not tricking me are you remember
the Sixth Sense reveal just affected one
guy in his perception of reality The
Village messed with everyone on the
property props to the elders for holding
on to that simple life for as long as
you could but you can't tell me that
William Hurt and Sigourney Weaver never
snuck out to grab some Arby's when
everyone else was asleep they shunned
the modern world technically they know
who LeBron and Beyonce are right they
probably saw the sixth sense in theaters
like the rest of us the village gets the
final point of the day which means that
the sixth sense and its two overall
points get the victory in this epic M
Night Shyamalan movie Twister turn it
around positive thinking congrats to
those two movies and signs and glass for
getting on the scoreboard in one of the
most competitive matches in the history
of this year program which you can now
watch in convenient playlist for him on
the YouTube head on over subscribe to
the Rotten Tomatoes Channel and let the
good times roll you got Robocop versus
Terminator Batman vs Superman one time
we made all the James Bonds battle each
other it's a fun show I like hosting it
thanks for watching comment below with
your favorite M Night Shyamalan talking
picture and until next time I'm Mark
Ellis reminding you to swing away
[Applause]